- But this is my favorite thing,
or one of my favorite things I've seen
in the quarantine that's happened.
This is a photo of you as Tiger King,
and it's my favorite because
it just says so much about you
as a human as well.
Like you're so there for the joke.
Whose idea was this, was it yours?
- Well, you're right, I do
like to find the fun in things.
I do enjoy giving people
some light in their lives,
and like everybody, I was
obsessed with Tiger King.
And like every actor, I
was like that's the part
of a lifetime.
(Kelly laughs)
Every once in awhile, they let
me out of my leading man jail
and I get to do "Behind the Candelabra"
or like the "Drew Peterson" story.
And I thought maybe
this is the next thing.
So my wife, Sheryl,
before she was a successful
jewelry designer,
she was one of the leading makeup artists
in the movie business when we met.
All of that is a beautiful, on-the-spot,
sort of prosthetic makeup that Sheryl--
- Wow.
- Yeah.
And that's why it looks
so particularly great,
and then I substituted my little dog Bella
for the tiger.
- That's awesome.